what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and super and today we're
going to be talking about doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness
specifically the illuminati scene for
multiverse of madness and how i don't
think what happened is actually going to
remain that way but what if i actually
told you that while things might not
have gone 100 according to the
illuminati's plan they still didn't
actually lose control over the situation
and there was a contingency plan put in
place in case something bad happened now
that's all i'm going to say without
issuing a spoiler warning if you have
not seen doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness and you care about
spoilers now's the time to click away
but if you've seen it or you simply
don't care let's talk about how the
illuminati could have been and probably
were brought back to life using the time
stone and the more i think about this
theory it actually solves a bit of a
problem that i had with mr fantastic and
the entire illuminati and it makes me
feel a little bit better about what
happened and if you're feeling a little
bit uneasy about how easily they died
this theory will probably make you feel
better so let's dive into it and of
course if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest marvel videos now to start
off i really didn't like how easily the
illuminati lost to the scarlet witch now
having said that i totally get it i
understand what this scene was for and
michael waldron the writer of loki and
multiverse of madness has explained why
they killed everybody according to him
they did this scene so everybody would
truly fear the scarlet witch and know
just how powerful she was and success
that was a very big success on their
part that's exactly what that scene did
it creeped us out and really showed us
how strong the scarlet witch was but
this is the illuminati the most powerful
beings in the universe i mean we have
professor xavier mr fantastic captain
marvel black bolt captain carter and
they got beat pretty badly but here's
the theory they're not actually dead yes
they did die but what if mordo used the
time stone to bring them all back to
life the more i think about this theory
the more it makes sense now credit to
joe on twitter at doctor strange atl for
coming up with the base of this theory
that mordo probably has the time stone
and would probably use it to resurrect
the illuminati and here's why i think
this is actually what probably happened
reed richards they literally introduced
him in the movie as the smartest man
alive and i thought it was pretty
cavalier of the illuminati to kind of
just brush off the scarlet witch in fact
captain marvel literally calls her a
little witch very arrogantly she says oh
we can handle your little witch if she
decides to dreamwalk here's my issue i
get that they are extremely powerful but
they are a part of the illuminati reed
richards and mordo are both a part of
this illuminati and reed richards was
very good friends with dr strange who
was also the founder of the illuminati
and the illuminati clearly knows what
dreamwalking is so i'm going to assume
that they know who the scarlet witch is
and how powerful she is and since reed
richards is the smartest man alive i
really doubt that he would be so
careless with the scarlet witch i
actually think it's quite the opposite i
actually think that reed richards pretty
much knew that they wouldn't be able to
defeat wanda because after the death of
blackvult reed richard just kind of
reaches for wanda and i always thought
well what exactly are you planning to do
there mr fantastic there's not much you
can do which was proven because he then
instantly died and here's the other
thing if you look closely at everybody's
facial expressions in the illuminati
when they're fighting the scarlet witch
and they all start to die they aren't
really too horrified no one seems that
shocked and perhaps this could be
because maybe morta used the time stone
to look into the future very similar to
what doctor strange did in avengers
infinity war with thanos if reed
richards and morta were on the same team
it would make sense that reed would say
mordo can you look into the future and
see what the outcome of this is we have
a new doctor strange here from another
universe what exactly is about to happen
maybe mordo saw into the future and
realized that they're not going to be
able to beat the scarlet witch and that
ultimately it will come down to doctor
strange from earth 616 and america
chavez defeating the scarlet witch the
only thing they needed to do was slow
her down so she doesn't get america
chavez at least not right away and even
though they saw their deaths they could
also see past them because mordo was
still alive this would enable mordo to
reverse literally everything that
happened at the baxter building
including everybody's deaths now i know
one of the big questions out there is
why didn't the avengers use the time
stone to revive tony stark well tony
stark's death was caused by all of the
infinity stones which most likely made
it irreversible by only one stone that's
pretty much the best explanation that
we've heard so far but a death caused by
another person by the scarlet witch is
completely reversible and we've actually
seen this proven to be true in the first
doctor strange movie if you recall at
the end of the movie wong was actually
dead he died but doctor strange used the
time stone to reverse what had happened
including the death of wong so that
establishes the fact that the time stone
absolutely has the capability to reverse
what went down in the baxter building
including all of their deaths and it was
very convenient that mordo was the only
person left alive wasn't it the sorcerer
supreme was the person left alive the
person that knows how to work the time
stone was left alive and even before he
started fighting with doctor strange and
got sort of trapped down there in that
chamber he was still the only one that
never went to battle the scarlet witch
he was always the one that was supposed
to remain behind plus we have to think
about what professor xavier said as well
he sort of guided doctor strange he told
him about how to get the vashanti almost
like he pretty much knew what was about
to happen the scarlet witch would kill
them all except for mordo but doctor
strange would outrun wanda get the
vashanti until eventually wanda would
catch up grab america chavez but again
their job was to kind of just slow the
scarlet witch down i don't think anybody
could defeat the scarlet witch i think
that was the point of the illuminati
scene she had to beat herself so it
always came down to strange and america
chavez helping wanda realize that she
had become a monster and if you noticed
in the illuminati scene where they're on
titan where they actually killed thanos
if you look at his gauntlet he does not
have the time stone he never got the
time stone from doctor strange at the
time because remember strange was
sorcerer supreme before morta was in
that universe so we can assume that the
origin of the doctor strange in that
universe was kind of similar to ours on
earth 616. started as a doctor got in
the accident hands don't work anymore
found the carmitage became a sorcerer
used the time stone to become a great
sorcerer being able to study in which
would have normally taken days and
probably years in only a short amount of
time due to the time stone that's how
strange became so knowledgeable and
powerful so quickly so we can assume the
same thing happened here and that doctor
strange had the time stone and then
eventually that went to mordo so we can
establish a few things here one is that
thanos did not have the time stone this
was made clear in the titan scene where
we saw in the gauntlet it wasn't there
since morta was the sorcerer supreme he
most likely had the time stone and reed
richards the smartest man alive was
obviously familiar with the infinity
stones because they had to fight thanos
and since doctor strange in that
universe was the original person to form
the illuminati and was a good friend of
reed richards in fact when mr fantastic
comes out you can see that he's actually
kind of happy to see doctor strange he
says steven and he smiles and when
doctor strange even makes fun of him he
smiles again because he kind of misses
his old friend so they were good friends
and part of the illuminati together
which means they've probably fought
together before which means doctor
strange has probably used the eye of
agamotto slash timestone before and mr
fantastic being the smartest man alive
would probably realize that they could
look into the future to see the outcomes
of certain things and then if things
didn't go according to plan they could
use the time stone to reverse what had
happened in fact that universe seems to
be a little bit more advanced and this
could actually be due to the time stone
being able to reverse certain tragic
events that would happen in the universe
and the world so i believe one of two
things happened or both of these
happened the first one is that the time
stone is simply a contingency plan if
anything bad happens to the illuminati
mordo uses the time stone to bring them
all back the second thing that could
have happened also involves the first
part but it involves also using the time
stone to look forward into the future to
know what's about to happen they could
have seen that the scarlet witch would
kill them all but they kind of had to
die so they could slow her down but the
plan then would still be to use the time
stone to bring the back this technically
also shouldn't affect incursion that
much since doctor strange america chavez
and the scarlet witch were only in their
universe for maybe an hour and since
they can reverse all the damage that
have been done it shouldn't really
affect it and in the eyes of mr
fantastic and the illuminati that would
probably make everything that was about
to go down okay not ideal since they all
but mordo die but still at the end of it
all everything would be the same and
eventually the scarlet witch would go on
to destroy the darkhold which is
something that the illuminati would
probably want but this is just a theory
let me know what you think about it in
the comments down below i personally
think that since mr fantastic is such a
genius he probably would have thought of
something like this but let me know what
you think don't forget to like the video
and subscribe for more marvel videos for
live updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof